what we're going to do in this video is
think about monetary policy which is
policy that a central bank can use to
affect the economy in some way this is
often contrasted with fiscal policy and
that would be a government deciding to
tax or spend in some way in order to
make adjustments to an economy but to
help us think through monetary policy
let's bring up our model for the money
market and just as a little bit of a
review here on the horizontal axis I
have the quantity of money less we could
imagine that say the m1 which is cash
and circulation and checkable deposits
and then here in the vertical axis we
have our nominal interest rate in this
model we have assumed a perfectly
inelastic money supply that's where we
have this vertical line which isn't
exactly how the world works but we'll go
with that for the sake of this video and
then we have the demand curve for money
at high nominal interest rates the cost
the opportunity cost of keeping cash is
very high so people would not want to
keep much of it around and then when
nominal interest rates are low the
opportunity cost or at least the
perceived opportunity cost of holding
cash is a lot lower so people might want
to hold more of it and so you have a
higher demand for money and this point
where the supply and the demand
intersect we have seen this before this
point of equilibrium we see that that
would result in our equilibrium nominal
interest rate but let's say this is the
world that we are in and we are in a
recessionary or a negative output gap
and you are the central bank of this
country what could you do well in
general you would say well it would be
nice if interest rates if nominal
interest rates were lower then maybe
people would be willing to borrow more
there'd be more of a demand for money
and they would use that money in order
to make investments or in order to
consume more and we could close that
recessionary gap but how would you lower
interest rates well one way would be to
increase the money supply if we could
shift this vertical line to the right
somehow but how would you do that we
often talk about central bank's print
but how do they get that money actually
into circulation how do they actually
increase the money supply well there's a
couple of tools at their disposal one is
the idea of open market operations open
market operations and this is the tool
that central bank's most typically use
let's say that this is a bond that I
currently own and a bond is a loan to
some entity in this paper says hey that
entity is going to pay you back with
interest at some point in the future and
let's say this is a government bond
let's say it's to the US government what
it what the Federal Reserve might do in
the United States the central bank is
this is how most central bank's work the
Federal Reserve says hey I want to
increase the money supply and so they
say hey I'm gonna go into the open
market and buy a bond so I might not
know who's buying that bond but it
happens to be the Federal Reserve and so
instead of selling it to someone else
who would who would give me cash that's
already in circulation the Federal
Reserve would be introducing new cash
into circulation this might be money
that they just printed and I'll say
printed in quotes because there's not a
lot of physical cash or at least as much
as there used to be these could just be
digital numbers in banking accounts at
certain places but it has the same
functional idea that this is part of the
monetary base and then we've talked
about this before you have a money
multiplier I would put this into a bank
the bank would loan out a proportion of
that based on the reserve requirements
and then whoever gets that would deposit
in a bank and then that bank could loan
out a certain proportion let's say that
the central bank bought this from me for
one thousand one thousand dollars and
let's say that our current reserve
requirement is equal to twelve point
five percent well the effect on the
money supply over here won't just be one
thousand dollars instead we would move a
thousand dollars times the money
multiplier and so this would be equal to
so we would have one thousand dollars
and what's the multiplier are going to
be well it's going to be one over twelve
point five percent is
point one two five one over 0.125 this
right over here is eight so the money
multiplier here is eight so the effect
of buying that thousand dollar bond with
new printed currency so to speak printed
cash so to speak would actually be to
increase the money supply by $8,000
$8,000 increase in money supply and
obviously $8,000 is not going to make a
big deal to an economy like the United
States but imagine if this was hundred
billion dollars well then this would be
eight hundred billion dollars right over
here and what would happen to this curve
well it would move over let's say it
moves over here and so this is money
supply curve - and then this is M - and
now what is our equilibrium interest
rate well our equilibrium interest rate
our nominal interest rate has now gone
down our - and this would hopefully have
the effect that the central bank wants
that hey now that nominal interest rates
have gone down people might borrow more
for more consumption for more investment
and close that negative output gap and
it could work the other way as well
imagine if in this situation right over
here
we were in an inflationary output gap a
positive output gap the economy was
overheating in some way and the central
bank wanted to cool things down well the
way they could do is they could say well
if interest rates were a little bit
higher that might slow things down there
might be less consumption less
investment how would they do that well
instead of what they did here were they
bought bonds to inject cash they could
do the opposite they could take bonds
that the central bank has and they could
sell those bonds and then that would
take cash out of the system by taking
though that cash out of the system it
would take reserves out of the system
and it would have the opposite effect
and it would shift the money supply to
the left and then you would have the
effect of raising rates now another way
of shifting the money supply to the
right or the left here increasing or
decreasing it is by changing the actual
reserve requirement this is done less
frequently than the open market
operations but we'll see that that could
have the same
if the central bank which can set the
reserve requirement were to change it
from 12 and a half percent and were to
instead make it let's say 10% well then
the money multiplier money multiplier
when we've done the math in other videos
it would go from one over 12.5%
it would go from eight to one over ten
percent to ten so the existing reserves
instead of having an eight times
multiplier on them you would have a ten
times multiplier on them and once again
that would have the effect of increasing
the money supply
now another tool that sometimes
associated with monetary policy is
setting the discount rate now the
discount window at the Federal Reserve
in the United States isn't used in
situations to effect monetary policy so
much as really being in a mechanism of
safety for our financial system so if a
bank is running out of reserves and so
they can still hold up their commitments
to folks they can go to the discount
window of the Federal Reserve and borrow
money directly from the Fed and the
Federal Reserve can set this discount
rate but it really becomes operational
during emergencies when you hear about
the Federal Reserve setting the rate
they're really talking about the federal
funds rate federal funds and this is the
rate at which banks lend reserves to
each other overnight and the banks are
going to be lending to each other at
slightly different rates but what the
Federal Reserve the central bank will do
is they'll set a target federal funds
rate so what they will do is they will
target a federal funds rate and
typically use open market operations to
make that target a reality now the last
thing I want you to appreciate in this
discussion of monetary policy the things
that the Federal Reserve can do to
increase or decrease the money supply to
decrease or increase nominal interest
rates is to think about how quickly
these things might happen and how
quickly their effects might be there's
oftentimes a lag here it might take a
little time for the central bank to
realize hey it looks like we're in an
inflation
situation maybe we got to decrease the
money supply a little bit maybe we got
to take a little bit of reserves out of
the system or the other way around to
realize that they're in a recession so
there's usually a lag there and then
even once they act they enacted this
monetary policy it takes time for it to
fully impact the system it takes time
for the interest rates to truly come
down and even more once the interest
rates are down it might take time for
people to realize that hey maybe I want
to borrow now and what would I use that
money for and that for that to actually
impact the economy